Okay.
Let's go next to our color from the two one
four area code.
Who's calling today from two one four.
Hello?
Yeah, that's you.
Oh, hi.
Hi.
Who's this?
My name is Melissa
amylose.
So what's on your mind today?
Um, recently, um, my mom who works in a restaurant
was robbed at gunpoint.
Um, it was, yeah, it wasn't, the person was
unmasked and the person came in, brought the,
like, I think they had someone come in and
just like scout the place to see if there
was a low end customers, which there was at
that time.
And so she was robbed at gun point.
And so I almost lost my mom to gun violence,
which is something that happens a lot and
I don't really hear any other candidates talking
about, um, gun control for wanting to know.
Um, I dunno.
I feel like, especially where I'm from, there
is a lot of push back whenever we talk about
gun control.
So where, where is it that this happened?
Melissa?
What part of the country?
Texas.
Okay.
Um, I mean, so here's the, here's the unfortunate
sort of reality on the gun issue.
Um, it appears from the more we learn about
this, it appears that there is very little
upside for Democrats, particularly in the
primary to get into disagreements or even
debate the issue of gun control because, um,
they, there doesn't seem to be significant
electoral upside to doing it, particularly
not at this point in time as a general thing.
It's not clear how many people in this country
at, in national, excuse me, in national elections,
are voting on the basis of, uh, of the gun
issue.
And I think that there's just a reality that
right now there's very little incentive for
the Democratic candidates to start arguing
with each other very much on the issue of
guns.
You saw some disagreements actually during
the debate when the topic of guns came up,
but I just think there's not an advantage
to democrats delving into it too, too much
now.
You'll probably see it more in the general
election.
Okay.
Yeah.
My thing is, so people always say like one
of the main defenses is, um, if we outlaw
guns on the outlaws will have guns.
So, I mean, how do we convince people?
I know, I think like they say that guys who
always have guns, but is that true?
If we do,
no, it's not.
I mean, if you look at lots of other countries,
you see that, that that's not the case.
And the thing is, it's very easy to say, if
we change nothing other than putting a bunch
of guns on a now illegal list, then people
who follow the law won't have those guns.
And people who break the law will have those.
Yeah.
Obviously.
But that's just a very cartoonish and simplistic
way of thinking about it.
We're talking about much broader changes that
relate to the accessibility of these guns,
the number of these guns that are even in
circulation or available at all.
Again, most most guns that eventually fall
into the hands of someone who obtains the
gun illegally or is going to commit a crime
with it.
At some point that gun was legally manufactured
and there was some kind of legal initial entry
into the system.
So it's a, it's too simplistic of an, of an
argument to say if you outlaw guns, only outlaws
will have, will have guns.
It's not even really like a serious argument
that's made.
I know.
And so I just think like now my mom is very
fearful.
Yeah, go to work.
And I have armies like how can, we're supposed
to be a really great country, this amount
of the free, but if you've empowered the freedom
school, like she never knows who's going to
walk in now and have a gun.
And it's like, how, how can we justify this?
Is She thinking about getting a gun?
I don't know.
I mean, I know I'm familiar with allow her
to carry again, I don't know how, I'm not
just milling with gun losses, but I'd never
really been interested in guns.
Right.
I don't know anything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, Melissa.
Yeah.
I mean, it's an intractable problem and I'm
really sorry about what happened, but I, I
appreciate you calling in and telling me about
it.
All right.
Take care.
Uh, okay.
That does it for calls today.
Sorry to everybody that I didn't get to.
We'll take calls again and I look forward
to hearing more folks.